i'd like you guys to think what you
would like a freestyle rap about and we
will get five suggestions we will drop a
beat and have some fun and the first
suggestion is going to come from someone
over here what would you like
you said asparagus which is a food um
but
but it's preferable to colonization by
this
young man in the front row
let's let's let's pull up a stool and
have this
thorny discussion
[Laughter]
you're you are from a colony what's your
name
i'm not even going to try i apologize
my ancestors would not help
they would have called you boy and i
apologize for that
i
[Applause]
i can't believe you're applauding that
that is
absolutely disgusting um
so
what what about let's be more specific
let's kind of drill down into this
what specifically about colonization
i don't know everything i guess
everything but now we can we can we can
hone in on a specific topic
railways okay cool yeah
the kind we left behind that don't work
anymore well i mean they are 160 years
old right
you guys should have done some upkeep
that's
i know we frisk people for weapons on
the way in right good okay
you've left your onion rings untouched
was that was that a gamble and you've
decided you didn't like them
but you've been here a while because
you're wearing a uc irvine hoodie
yeah yeah but did you not go there
you did no
yeah i know i know that i know that
it's getting awkward so
a little bit red colonization but
specifically the railways and asparagus
shouted over there
i'm glad you're excited
just you're just like anything but that
awkward interaction
asparagus and colonization railways um
middle of the room please do not bring
up any of the apparent things my country
did in this past and uh
what would you like a wrap about the use
of vaseline the use of vaseline thank
you yes
i'm just waiting for you at the side of
the stage be like actually that was
something you stole from us and
now that was the coin
front off
front of the room what would you like a
rap about
i'm going to let you say that into the
microphone
because i think several people at the
back will ejaculate
would you just would you repeat that
licking weenuses thank you
but for those of you that don't know the
weenus is the colloquial term for the
bit of skin dangling on the end of your
elbow opposite the more medically named
antecubital fossa
licking weenuses
over here what would you like a rap
about the queen the queen i i feel that
that feels too obvious that feels too
kind of you know
oh let's be more imaginative than that
you can make give the queen an activity
[Laughter]
don't say colonizing
the queen existing
you count that as an activity
okay the queen existing licking
weanesses
asparagus
the uses of vaseline colonization on the
railways okay cool
this is a freestyle that is a rat made
upon the spot usually they're very very
good
if this one is not good you know who to
blame
my lovely band are gonna are gonna
bring bring together all the sounds in
the universe and create something
magical let's see what that's gonna
sound like
[Applause]
feel that tension they're like yeah
chris
this is disgraceful
and horrendous
and let's uh have some fun
we'll skate past this quickly got a lot
of fuss we're moving on the first one
taking that asparagus i like it i never
feel fear even though the veg is green
it be shaped like a spear i like it i'll
explain let me talk you gotta break it
snap it at the stalk don't use a knife
on the hard little pip if you just bend
it where it splits is the perfect place
and then you blanch it maybe get a
little bit of steam and i ask it do you
want some bamboo do you want some lemon
or some butter maybe get some capers but
later you'll discover if you go into the
loo coming in the steam a whiff off your
piss you can smell that urine you're
like whoa hey it quite long in the past
but still i smell that piss pong it'd be
making sense i'd be at the orion a guy's
like you had an asparagus night y'all
i'd be like yeah i should have used the
cubicle and keep the little aroma away
from y'all maybe i could talk about this
in my dream i like to keep moist using
pot of vaseline i take it by the side of
my bed it's not smelly what's it come
from that's petroleum jelly the brand
name with the vas vaseline i like to put
it on my weeness i keep it kind of moist
opposite of dry and if this lady on the
street catches my eye i'll be like don't
worry i'll give you a choice the
vaseline pot keeps my wieners moist i
like to hold my arm out at a little
angle but then i make it flex watch my
weiners hang you all going down low
going down deep you'll be going down on
your knees and saying ah ever so glad
that i seen this tongue out hard and
you're golfing on the weiners ever so
weird i could pay a pretty penny what's
the queen do she exists for many many
many many years and decades you think by
now she would have decayed but she
hasn't she still persists in a home
buckingham palace you got the liz on the
throne if you say what's that diamond on
your wrist she says i stole it in the
past and still exist it's kind of weird
it's kind of absurd you might think the
crown jewels they wouldn't come out as
cursed because we got them that was an
ill-gotten prize we came over when we
decide to colonize we walk in saying
hello you can i steal this plunder and
get the jewels going off to bangalore
going off to other places and taking all
the treasure right in front your faces
you're like whoa when will you go away
we're like don't worry got some prize to
say we're going to display this inspire
y'all today look what we made some
lovely railways and you'd be like now
they're rotting just a bit to say in
these ill-gotten games they don't fit
but railways you gotta keep them up i
beseech you maybe replace the rails
gander sleepers then all the trains go
through it's amazing i know it's kind of
weird i'm trying to gauge engaging
that's a railway pun whoever thought
colonization could be fun well not these
two guys they're not into you they'll
put a one-star review we're from india
we didn't like it we thought it's really
really [ __ ] but on the plus side who
expected rap from a british
[Applause]